if you are
correct about the hazard here uh
my guess i think as you have already
said
is that there's no stopping this
campaign that is
in some sense politically inconceivable
that people would change course
even if it made perfect sense for them
to do so
and so the criteria you suggest might
tell us
that your model is correct standard
hypothetical deductive science you've
put out a hypothesis here are the
characteristics that you would expect to
indicate that it's right
if it turns out it's right what do we do
next
do you have a sense well
do you mean in terms of to remedy the
situation uh
i mean my point is uh
you know the best thing that can happen
to somebody
is to to to be zero negative right
because if you're zero negative
certainly certainly if you are
in good health and your sero-negative
you have good natural antibodies again
this is no fantasy there are studies
scientific studies where
even natural antibodies are defined
or are used as a benchmark for good
health
right so if you're zero negative
you you don't suffer from any antibodies
that could block
your natural antibodies and
you can be fully exposed i mean of
course the problem is gonna be
the more you vaccinate people the more
people
are gonna gonna be sitting on long lift
on long-lived antibodies right
and even if those antibodies decline
and they get re-exposed to the virus i
mean these antibodies will be
immediately recalled you were pointing
out you were educating people on what is
memory
and how antibodies get recalled after
re-exposure right
so then you have of course
uh well being zero negative is not going
to be easy and
i tell you why because if we if we
continue
to breed these highly infectious
variants
the likelihood for somebody who is
seronegative
to become infected is is gonna become
higher and higher of course
so at the end of the day you can turn it
the way you want
for me there is only one solution at
this point in time
maybe not at the beginning where there
was a wild uh just the wild say
that at this point in time there is no
other solution but
but to intervene and for me the the only
intervention that makes sense is
really to eradicate those uh those
variants rings
because nobody is telling us how we are
ever gonna get rid of those right uh
hurt immunity well i mean that's not
gonna happen obviously because
you know we have it's not going to
happen because people will have been
exposed to different
variants and therefore it's
you know it's a family of viruses yeah
you know
not uh not a single but remember this
was the final target this was the end
game of the vaccination of the mass
vaccination
is to have hurt immunity right so
you could you could of course also and
i'm not the expert but let's
assume an antiviral would work and this
antiviral could even be things like
ivermectin you you don't hear me
advocating for ivory mechan but let's
assume
some kind of antiviral drug would work
you could you could imagine to treat
also people with
with this antiviral but doing this in a
prophylactic way
you're going to have the same problem as
with antibiotics that
some people you know will have low
concentration be confronted with the
virus and
it will induce resistance i think uh at
the end
so you can use this for early treatment
that that i think is very very useful
but to get rid really of all these
variants
and to reduce the infectivity and
control the whole thing
i really see no other way but to have a
vaccine that induces
you can maybe explain this to the
audience sterilizing immunity
which is really to completely kill the
virus
no matter no no no matter what the
antigenic constellation is of the virus
but it is a very important so maybe i
don't know
well enough to explain it to the
audience i'd like to understand better
i certainly see that there is a hazard
um a vaccine is not a vaccine right a
vaccine
is a very general technology and in this
case
the narrow targeting of the vaccine
seems to me
it was a blessing in the sense that it
allowed the vaccine to be generated
very quickly but it's a curse in the
sense that it informs the immune system
only about the one
characteristic and that if we were to
use something like
a an inactivated virus that the immune
system
could discover various antigens
and therefore the evolution of a single
antigen would not create the kind of
escape
that we're seeing but you tell me
whether that adds up no
no it doesn't i think it's a very
logical reasoning but unfortunately
uh it does not apply the reason is if
you target
the s protein what most of these
vaccines do
you prevent you can prevent the virus
from entering into the cell
so that is basically that is that is
sufficient
if you know um
the problem is if you well let me put it
the other way around
instead of an inactivated virus
i think that might make sense because by
the way that is the way we eradicated
like smallpox that's also the uh
well the biggest rights in the
eradication of polio polio is not fully
eradicated but
almost but the biggest rights we have
made with the oral polio vaccine which
was also
a life attenuated vaccine and there of
course you induce
innate immune responses as well as of
course
adaptive immunity etc and that would be
i think in my humble opinion much more
efficient but of course it would not be
a solution for people who have already
been vaccinated
because as i was saying if you
re-vaccinate them with the oral polio
with the let's say an attenuated corona
virus you're going to recall
their original antibodies first because
those have memory
and there is something like we call this
antigenic sin
if you are re-challenged with an antigen
that is similar
to the one to which you got originally
primed
then your original antibodies are going
to be recalled
and those are not going to match with
with the variance so you
you you are going to even promote again
immune escape if you
re-vaccinate people who have previously
been vaccinated
with with the current vaccines but they
help for those who are
negative so you're attenuated
you're arguing so the attenuated
virus is one that functions to
transmit between cells
uh that function to transmit well it's
it's live attenuated so it's gonna be
uh secretly excreted right to some
extent
yeah some people will say it was also
the problem with with oral polio
that at the end of the day you put this
in the environment
it gets again in people it can recombine
etc but uh still as we have seen with
oro polio it has dramatically
dramatically
reduced viral loads but my
understanding is because of this
antigenic sin that you could not use it
in people who have already been
pre-crime
with with the current vaccine so this is
this is yet another argument
against the current regime is that the
current vaccine
regime actually eliminates what might be
our best weapon
going forward because it will induce a
kind of immunity that will react
to uh this alternative type of vaccine
this breath is something people need to
understand in contrast to
a drug you have a drug when that gets
eliminated from your
blocks or you know you have the the the
half time of the
you need the minimum concentration for
the direct to be active
if you're below that concentration it
doesn't work anymore it's eliminated
and you're fine it's done you know there
is no
there is no consequence so to say a
vaccine
is something that educates your immune
system for god's sake for the rest of
your life
right so that is not a simple thing that
is something which has serious
consequences i mean
we were talking about the memory what is
memory
well memory means that if you see this
antiquation
again or something alike your antibodies
your
original immune response will be
recalled right
yes so that is a serious thing i i've
been trying to
to call my audience's attention to this
that
we are inherently intervening
not just in a complex system right
complex systems are tough enough
but you're you're intervening in a
complex system within a complex system
within a complex system
right the narrowest one being the immune
system which you are educating
the immune system existing inside the
body which is itself an adaptive system
and then it exists inside a population
and so all of these things interact and
what they do
is they mean that any action that you
take because it sounds like the right
thing to do
risks creating a cascade of consequences
you did not anticipate
this being one such consequence that
there is a tool
that would take longer to develop that
you will take off the table to the
extent
that you have educated people's immune
system such that effectively
you've warned them about a pathogen your
next vaccine might be
attenuated and effectively the immune
system would have the equivalent of
post-traumatic stress disorder where it
would react
to the attenuated vaccine which is
potentially life-saving
um it would react to it as if it were a
pathogen and it would prevent the
effectiveness
is that what you're saying well it will
recall your original antibodies and
these are the
s antibodies uh of the current vaccines
right
which uh which we know uh you know they
they they don't do the job essentially
let's assume
you you make this vaccine and you start
vaccinating with it in half
half a year from now in the meantime
you will have further evolution of
course of your variance so they will
even be
more different the s-protein from the
one that was originally in the vaccine
so now when you recall the original
antibodies
in one in half a year from now yeah
for sure they will match
much less with with with the s protein
of the variants that will
be circulating in half a year from now
right so it's so it's further driving
immune escape
[Music]
basically
[Music]
you